après plusieurs mois dans un brouillard
de restrictions le portugal pourrait
enfin entre apercevoir la lumière musée
collège et terrasses rouvre ce lundi
après plus de deux mois de fermeture un
plan de déconfinement commencé le 15
mars dernier avec la réouverture des
écoles primaires une levée des
restrictions permise par une
amélioration de la situation sanitaire
dans le pays ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la grèce qui voit le nombre de nouveaux
cas de comics 19 augmenté pourtant le
gouvernement a autorisé les magasins à
rouvrir pour le plus grand bonheur de
ses habitants
heureusement le marché a rouvert et nous
pouvons voir le retour des passants
j'espère que les mesures sanitaires
seront maintenus et que les personnes
responsables car de rouleur l'instant ce
que nous leur course afin que le
gouvernement ne me ferme palme nous
sommes heureux d'être ouverts
aujourd'hui nous pensons que le public
répondra présent et qu'il viendra nous
avons déjà plusieurs appels et quelques
commandes
nous espérons que cela ne soit que le
début en difficulté économique en raison
de la faible activité touristique
athènes accélère sa stratégie de
déconfinement objectif accueillir des
touristes dès le mois de mai prochain
pour cela le gouvernement de kyriakos
mitsotakis comme ses homologues
portugais compte beaucoup sur la mise en
place d'un passeport sanitaire tous deux
voient donc d'un bon oeil les annonces
de londres boris johnson ayant annoncé
aujourd'hui le lancement d'un test de ce
dispositif prochainement ce qui est
certainement vrai c'est que l'idée d'un
certificat de vaccination sera
certainement utile pour les voyages
internationaux
c'est quelque chose sur quoi tous les
pays travaillent et je pense que les
touristes devront faire avec et nous
devons y penser
très avancé dans sa campagne de
vaccination avec plus de 30 millions de
personnes émues
et l'ex maire de londres se sait attendu
sur ce sujet polémique
chaque été des dizaines de milliers de
touristes britanniques se rendent dans
le sud de l'europe pour y profiter de
leurs vacances
une manne vitale pour la grèce comme
pour le portugal